ein
die so gar nicht daran denken den wir
auch aus
angst und
schaffen
[Musik]
deine ganze gekommen
hallo
[Musik]
ich verstand einfach
b
nein
[Musik]
der krieg schon wieder gehen in den
augen wenn ich daran denke wie die
eröffnung war aber ganz schön dass du da
man sich richtig viele dann am nächsten
tage sind
weitere 50 immer noch der eröffnungs
ansturm habe gerade tag war und noch mal
als ich war so aufgeregt wegen es die
eigentlich war gar nicht aufgeregt weil
ich bist du das risiko der kasse
beschäftigt haben noch programmiert
aber der moment wo ich aber so krause
guckt hallo ich ja okay das ist krank
das krasse ist denn du bist ja in meiner
hand der sackbauer honeycomb die leute
glaubt mir event.com und es wird richtig
voll und ich denke bei anderen leuten
die sachen immer super positiv und bei
mir selber negativ und dachte so okay
wenn 20 leute kommen gehen noch so 10 15
leute von der nikolaus dann hätten wir
mehr dann ist das nicht so peinlich aber
ich konnte so viel torte hunderte wenn
nicht sogar an die 1000 menschen das war
also ich hab kein baugebiet serie und
ich gehe nun durch die reihen und denken
so dass viele menschen also den tag
verteilt wird es ungefähr ich glaube
3000 das schon kann ja das ist krank das
ist wirklich krank
[Musik]
der gewinner hat vom jahresvorrat
industrie und als aufgebraucht die
lanker viele gesagt wurde genau ein jahr
ich habe auch bisschen verschenkt
bewusst sie
ja auf jeden fall wird nach schon einmal
von air berlin nach bochum gefahren nach
nicht
[Musik]
also ich wusste ich wusste schon was
dass viele konkret geht nach der liste
von leuten bekommen direkt gesprochen er
wollte ich wissen was sponsor dass die
leute was trinken können weil lange
wartezeit da ich wusste auch dass die
leute wahrscheinlich zwei oder drei
stück warten müssen und dann habe ich
quasi die getränke führte ja was wir
auch gemacht haben waren wir haben
unsere leckeren griffen harte sitze
verteilt haben ramona verteilt einfach
weil mir das auch ein bisschen leiter
hat wie lange die menschen gewartet
haben man muss sagen die kritiker vorne
also sowohl mit dem café die haben gas
gegeben ohne ende ja wenn der andrang so
groß ist kommt eine harte zeit einfach
zu standen eigentlich voll gemein ich
sowas wartet doch einfach kopflos
getränke bekommen
[Musik]
aber wie passt das denn jetzt dass wir
so viele leute dich an dem tag umarmt
oder ducati natürlich kennt ja das war
schön vor allem also die community kennt
mich halt irgendwie gefüllt in und
auswendig und immer wenn ich euch sehe
weiß ich wer hinter der community steckt
also dann wenn ich euch immer mehr und
immer besser kennen und ich habe so
unfassbar viele menschen umarmt
gesprochen smalltalk erhalten fotos
gemacht und ist kasse ist dieser tag
habe ich jetzt noch gesagt das war für
mich ein gefühl von letzter schultag
jetzt endlich ferien jetzt bin ich frei
die letzten monate waren prüfung
abgegeben ich ab jetzt frei und dann
einen tag später war alles anders
auch hier auch wenn wir so weit
innerlich ja wie auch der hochzeitstag
das stimmt dieses ganze begrüßen fotos
machen das war auch der hat sich einen
gut verdienen
mehr
also im endeffekt kann ich die kritik
von zugesagt haben sie die welt das
nicht schafft und seitlich wir müssen
die schlange karten und ich so nah und
doch so nah und doch so scheiße das war
schon hart und haben ich habe extra bis
dahin ausgesetzt haben wir gleich machte
gleich aber irgendwann konnte ich habe
am ersten tag haben wir auch richtig
überzogen das ding ist wir sind ja in
einem center genau bis 21 uhr überzogen
und die regel öffnungszeiten vom ruhr
park wird ist schon sinnvoll bis 10 10
bis 20 uhr und wir dürfen auch nach 20
uhr eigentlich gar nicht mehr verkaufen
haben da so ein bisschen die regel
gebrochen und habe überzogen aber
grundsätzlich an extremen tagen jetzt in
diesen tagen musste man um 18.30 oder
fast schon 19 uhr die schlange kappen
weil wir dürfen einfach nicht bedienen
nach 20 ordner und deswegen
das auch hart ist schon teilweise ohne
pause herzen tagen gewesen weil wir
einfach keine zeit hat und es ist auch
nur menschen und kein roboter wie war
das jetzt für dich so dass schulden weg
und dann schauen viele hatten
verständnis einige haben wirklich mit
dem kopf geschüttet was mich extrem
traurig gemacht hat weil wir haben alles
menschenmögliche getan haben schnell
gearbeitet wir haben extrem viel da
gehabt wir haben gas gegeben und
irgendwann waren halt war halt der
anderen zu groß irgendwann kann man
einfach nicht mehr wenn es so ist
teilweise wurde einmal auch die kiku
beleidigt wenn ich da vor ort gewesen
wäre da also ich finde sowas geht kasse
gemacht doch ganz ehrlich da werde ich
einmal auch ein bisschen frech geworden
ist will man nicht eigentlich nicht den
ausstellern das geht
dann ist halt so da könnte aber nicht
nötig das stimmt das ist der punkt hören
sie nicht zurück ihm unity und 90
prozent der menschen ein super
verständnisvoll und an der stelle danke
ich auch noch mal jeden fürs warten für
die geduld für die lange anreise auch
gestört vielen dank dass ihr alle zwei
verliebten mit offen herzlich willkommen
die hätten liege das stroh soll viren
ich danke gegend einzelnen vorher
gekommen ist haben die gleichen daten
die in foren und
dann gefahren ich wünsche euch noch
einen wunderschönen abend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nochmals vielen dank an alle die
gekommen sind vielen dank an alle die
noch kommen werden ich freue mich auf
euch wir sind immer da montags bis
samstags von 10 bis 20 uhr und wir geben
immer unser bestes leute und könnt euch
einfach die leckeren kaffee schaut euch
die produkte im store an zum anfassen
wäre so toll ist wie bekommen also kommt
mir schon klar sonst teuer bis zum café
alle sind wie glücklich und happy
jackpot das hat sich voll gelohnt
richtig kugeln geworden und wir lassen
es aber auch einfach also im café dass
das system wird sich auch ändern
wir haben schon die nächste idee und
kann wenn wir das so besser
wahrscheinlich dann
lasst euch überraschen leute lasst euch
überraschen und ansonsten war's das mit
unserer
videos
videos drehen die ganze sache auch den
ganzen frühling für ruhrpark gemacht und
wir haben gemacht und jetzt ist das
ganze
ja ich mache jetzt projekt also es dann
leute machten sind vorbei
[Musik]